[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREA THUMSHIRN: Very
good afternoon everybody.
I want to talk a little
bit about the last six
years of my life and how it
happened that I came to India.
So first of all I
want to show you
a small video that shows the
environment in which I spent
the last six years of my life.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
So now the question arises, why?
Why did I leave
my job, my family,
a good life in the
capital of Germany,
Berlin, to live in a tiny little
remote village in Rajasthan
to coach and teach the
children of the village?
I was always very adventurous.
I love to travel.
And I come from a very
sports-related family.
My grandfather, my grandmother,
my uncle, my auntie, my mother,
my father, my whole family was
engaged in the local sports
club.
We all grew up volunteering in
the sports club and coaching
and playing different
kind of sports.
And so it was in my
blood and I am what
I am today because of sports.
I started my own
travel agency so that I
could travel all the time.
And one of my favorite
destinations was India.
I was always traveling
around looking for new places
where I could bring my
clients off the beaten tracks
to show them the real country.
My business partner
came from Jaipur,
and his mother came
from a little village
which was halfway
between Agra and Jaipur.
So we thought it
would be a good idea
to bring our clients
for a lunch break
to a little Indian village,
show them the real village
life, traditional
life, colorful life,
and host them for a lunch break.
Maybe the kids of the village
could show their village
and the local family could
have some extra income.
So the family lived
in this ruined fort.
They were the former rulers, the
[NON-ENGLISH] of the village.
And I started dreaming of, maybe
I could teach them some hockey,
the village kids.
They have nothing to do.
And maybe we could have some
space in front of the fort
where we could start coaching.
So I shared my dream
with a local family.
And they would say,
yeah, you can have
the space in front of our fort.
We don't use that.
And you can try.
So in 2010 I was hosting
a veterans hockey
team from Vienna, from Austria.
And we brought
some hockey sticks
and we had a training
session with the kids.
And so the kids were so excited.
And then I started
dreaming that, this
would be a great
story if I could make
a difference in that village.
So obviously my business
was still in Germany
and I could only coach them once
in a while when I was in India.
Otherwise nothing much
happened in the village.
So I tried to hire
volunteers from Germany
who could bridge the
gap when I was not here,
but that somehow
didn't work out.
Then I thought,
OK, maybe I could
run my travel
business online and I
could sit in that village.
Maybe I would have less
clients than before but I
would need not so much
money to survive here
and I could coach
and teach the kids.
So, I gave everything
up in Germany.
I sold everything.
I closed my office and I
reconstructed two rooms
in that old fort.
And I called a
roller and a tractor
and we leveled the ground
here in front of the fort.
And we called the
kids for practice.
I went to the
local schools and I
wanted to especially encourage
the girls to play hockey
with me.
And I brought sticks
and I coached them
for a training
session and I invited
them to come in the
afternoon after school
to our hockey ground.
And I also tried to offer
them English classes
because I didn't
speak any Hindi.
They didn't speak any English.
So the mode of communication
was very basic.
There was an old
temple and the family
provided me one room which we
used as an open-air classroom.
And I started giving English
classes where some of the kids
would show up in the afternoons.
But I realized that traditional
Indian schooling system
where kids happily
repeat what you tell them
but their brains are not working
anyhow, that doesn't work much
and they don't learn anything.
So we started speaking
on the hockey grounds.
So actually all the kids learned
speaking English while playing.
This was our village
hockey ground.
We made a boundary wall
around and it was very dusty.
Especially during
the hot summers,
it was almost unbearable.
But the kids would show up
every day and they didn't mind.
And so we had a kind of
time-sharing agreement
with the local cows which
would rest on that place
while we were not playing.
And so the kids always
tried to sneak in late
because the first one
who came had to remove
the remainings of the cows.
We had so many kids that I
could not get hold of them
and they were very wild.
So I started learning
the colors in Hindi
and I bought T-shirts
in different colors
so that I could say the
[HINDI] group is there,
the [HINDI] is there, and
[HINDI] is over there.
And I got some older students
of the village who helped me
in coaching in the beginning.
So I tried to make
them understand,
and also for me, don't dream
your life, live your dream.
So then after one
year practicing,
I showed them the
movie "Chak De!
India".
They got very fascinated.
That was a funny
story because I bought
an old screen and a beamer
and invited the kids
to watch with me the movie.
And we brought the
cables out of the fort.
And there were some power
[INAUDIBLE] obviously also.
And we had to show the movie
when the sun was almost
going down so that
we can see the movie.
And we put some
chairs up and kids
were sitting on the ground.
And I was fascinated
watching the movie.
And I was so excited
about my idea.
And after half an
hour, I looked around
and only the farmers
were sitting around me
because the kids
already went home.
Because when it's getting
dark, they all have to go home.
So they only saw
half of the movie.
Nevertheless, they
got very much inspired
and they said, Andrea,
we also want to play.
So my friend, he
was the hockey coach
in the DPS school in
Jaipur, and they invited us
for our first match.
So we went by train to
Jaipur, which was already
the first big excitement.
And I feel so
privileged that I could
share all these first
moments with the kids.
They saw the big city.
They asked me, Andrea,
how to go [INAUDIBLE],,
like how they can go
up these huge buildings
and how all this traffic works.
And the first time
in their life they
were wearing sport
shoes, shin pads, socks.
So Chando, my local
partner and I,
we were sitting
next to each other.
One was putting up the socks.
One was putting
inside the shin pads.
And then we sent
them on the ground.
And the whole stadium was
filled with privileged children
in white school uniforms.
The green grass
was, wow, they've
never seen such a
grass in their life.
And we realized that we were
quite malnutrition compared
to the city children, which
were, according to the coach,
the same age group,
which I don't agree.
But yes, this was the next
lesson that we had to learn.
Life is not fair.
Especially when it comes
to sports and competition,
I had to learn my lesson
the hard way in India.
If it's under 14,
it's maybe under 17.
So then I thought, my
project needs more awareness.
I need to raise funds.
So how am I going to do this?
So I have to room
around the country.
So I bought a rickshaw.
And I drove from Jaipur to
[INAUDIBLE],, 2,400 kilometers--
[APPLAUSE]
--in 13 days.
And I can tell you it was the
best way to know the country.
Every 100 kilometers, a
different [NON-ENGLISH],,
different food.
The people were so
friendly and welcoming.
I had to I had to drink chai
with each and everybody.
Everybody wanted to know, what
the hell is that white woman
doing in that rickshaw?
And we had a two meter
hockey stick on the roof.
So we promote.
I mean, we didn't raise
any funds, to be honest.
But it was a great experience.
And we were in some
newspaper highlighted
and there was some awareness
of the project at least.
It was a great experience to
drive all along the country.
So I tried to encourage
the kids that you
have to sit in the driver's
seat of your car, of your life.
In villages, they are only
driven by the village society,
by their parents.
They do what the parents want.
And later on, they
do a job which
they don't want but the parents
want, that the neighbors want,
that whoever wants,
but not them.
So sports teaches you
to be self-confident,
to understand what
you want in your life.
So then obviously the
girls also wanted to play.
And my focus was
anyway on the girls.
The problem was just that
their school uniforms,
their skirts were quite long,
so it was very difficult to run.
And a regular hockey skirt would
be very brave for a village
girl to wear.
That was too short.
So then my fashion design
diploma came into accounts.
So I got a tailoring machine
and I tailored hockey
skirts which were a little
longer than the regular hockey
skirts.
And the girls loved them.
And I always had
my silver suitcase
where I put all the socks,
shin pads, shirts, and skirts,
and we would travel
with the train.
This time we went to
Haryana and the girls
had their first match.
But that was again, very
enthusiastic from my end
because I think
it was April, May.
It was like 40, 45 degrees.
It was burning hot.
And we had to wait for
them [NON-ENGLISH]..
[LAUGHTER]
Which is more important the
longer you have to wait.
So the first children already
fainted because of the heat.
And we finally had
then our match.
And this is my daughter Kavita.
So I took care of her.
She didn't have a mother.
And I brought her the best
Puma shoes from Germany.
And she said,
"Andrea, too tight."
She wanted to play barefoot.
She was the wild jungle kid.
She wanted to play barefoot
as per her convenience
and not with my good sport
shoes that I brought for her.
Then we played our first
All India KD Singh Babu
under-14 tournament, which
is by the way the only
under-14 tournament where
really under-14 teams are
playing, in Lucknow.
And they had a really,
really good sports canteen.
So in Rajasthan, most of the
families are vegetarians.
And it's even
you're a bad person
if you are a nonvegetarian.
So I'm from Germany.
I am a nonvegetarian.
So that was always some
blame to put on me,
or a bad influence that I have
on the children because I'm
eating nonveg.
So this is Lokesh.
He was our goalkeeper.
He was the smallest of all.
And he saw all the
other teams eating eggs
for breakfast and
butter and everything
and he was asking me, "Andrea,
if I eat eggs, I get strong?"
I said, "You can try."
So he went to the
buffet, he got one egg.
The whole team was watching him.
He survived the egg.
And all the others, one
by one, also took one egg.
By the end of the
tournament, everybody
had four eggs for breakfast.
And since that time, it
was always our secret.
If we went out for
tournaments together,
the first question was,
Andrea, we eat omelet?
So they knew that
this is something good
but they are not allowed
to eat this at home.
And somebody was even
asking me if his mother
can smell that he eat eggs.
They were literally scared.
So we always extended--
most of the time we were
out in the first round
on tournaments because
we were the youngest.
But to get more
experience, I always
asked the organizer if
we can stay some two,
three days longer.
First of all, you travel
all the way for one match.
And then the food is so good.
And they don't get that
kind of food at home.
Plus if they watch matches,
they also can learn a lot.
So we always extended
our stay and we
had lovely food every day.
This was the Nehru
Cup in Delhi where
they, together with
all the state teams,
were doing the march past.
And you can see here
our hand-painted flag.
And the kids were thrilled--
floodlight, [NON-ENGLISH]--
[LAUGHTER]
--AstroTurf in Delhi, wonderful.
So if you have a dream,
the sky's the limit.
Then the next crazy
thing I did was I
imported a secondhand
AstroTurf from Germany.
And it was quite an
action because it
was the first second-hand
AstroTurf that came to India
and nobody at the customs
knew how to handle that,
how to evaluate a second-hand
AstroTurf from Germany
and how much tax I have to pay.
So after I overcame this, the
huge truck with the AstroTurf
came from Gujarat
port to Rajasthan,
and we had a huge party.
And I thought like, wow,
my dream is coming true.
We have an AstroTurf.
I made it happen in Rajasthan.
There are only two AstroTurfs
and I have number three,
and I can make this
happen for these children.
And we had a huge party
and it was nice and great.
And the next morning, 8 o'clock,
Saturday, one of my girls
called me and she said, "Andrea,
please do come to the ground.
Police is there.
There is a problem."
So we went to the ground.
The groundwork was
already going on.
It was a government project.
And the sports ministry
sanctioned money.
Everything was nice.
Huge stones blocked
the entrance.
The [NON-ENGLISH] was sitting
there on a plastic chair.
And around 300 villagers
were singing freedom fighters
songs, [INAUDIBLE] go home.
Today she is ruling
the hockey ground.
Tomorrow she is ruling India.
We don't want history
to repeat itself.
I felt like, are they
talking about me?
What does that mean,
ruling the hockey ground?
I signed that this AstroTurf
will be government property
and I donate this
to the community.
All I want is that these kids
can play on an AstroTurf.
So I had to load my
AstroTurf again, rescue it
to another place, and
store it somewhere.
So the dream of the
AstroTurf was on hold.
Then I thought, OK, if my
kids cannot play in Rajasthan
on an AstroTurf, I
bring them to Germany.
So I took five boys for two
months in the summer holidays
to Germany where they stayed in
German families for two months,
had lovely German food, and
played in a German club.
And surprisingly they
could compete with the kids
of their age group.
And they got so much
exposure and so much
learning for their future
life that nobody can ever do
for them in their life again.
So they came back and everybody
was thinking that maybe they
don't want to go back.
But they were so bonded
with their families
and they were so proud
to tell of their stories
and bring all the
chocolates home
and benefit from
their experience
and tell everybody and
motivate all the other kids so
that there was a big
battle for the next year
that who would be the
privileged ones who
could come with me to Germany.
So since that
time, every year we
select some children,
the best ones who
are present in practice, good
in studies, good in hockey,
and good attitude,
good discipline,
and we take them to Germany.
And we find a lot of
sponsors in Germany
who support those hockey
clubs who host them
and who find it's a very
great idea to integrate them
in their teams.
So Deepak, my so-called
son, he was the lucky one.
He even went with
me to Switzerland.
And he was so amazed that
these cows give 40 liters milk
while his buffalo at
home gives maximum
one liter, which is
enough for a cup of chai
for his grandfather.
Then I thought,
OK, sports is good,
but I should involve
myself more in education
because that is what
counts at the end.
And out of that old
temple, we made a school.
So I had German
volunteers with me.
And with our own
hands, we knocked down
walls and ceilings.
And the whole village was
standing outside watching us,
how these white people
can do this labor
work, which is actually
the lowest level of work
that you can do.
And we were working hand in
hand with the local laborers who
earned like 250 rupees a day.
And we had a lot of fun.
We had a lot of fun to build
a school with our own hands.
And we started the first
English medium school
with our little ones.
So I want to show you a small
video from our school, how
we tried to teach the village
kids in a state of the art way.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So our school was a primary
school, English medium,
[INAUDIBLE] and class
one, two, three, and four.
Unfortunately, we also had to
shut down that school April
this year because our
local partner misused
foundation money.
And we bought land to lay out
that AstroTurf where you saw
where the kids were playing.
We already made a concrete
base to finally lay out
that AstroTurf.
So the dream was
a little closer,
but the local partner
registered the land in his name.
And we had to file a
big case against him.
And the result was that he was
threatening all the children
and was beating them
up in school, whoever
came for practice.
So out of 80 children
who were daily there
for practice, who played
for the district, who
played for the state, nobody
was allowed to come anymore.
We didn't get any
support from the parents.
And we were raising the
question that we can only work
and continue if you
stand by our side
and if you understand what
this project is all about.
And only one family
was standing up,
and they were even from
the neighboring village.
So we decided to
leave this place.
We got threatened for
our lives and there
was no way to continue.
So we got an offer from Coorg,
where there is obviously
more awareness about sports.
And we thought that maybe we
have a better start there.
It was a big decision to get
all the energy again together
and all the motivation and
overcome the bad experience
and struggle and loss that
we were facing in Rajasthan
and start again.
But we said OK, we do
it for the children.
And we packed a truck
with all our belongings,
mainly hockey equipment
and school equipment.
And we have two Labradors.
And so my husband and
I and the two Labradors
were in the truck.
And for 70 hours and
2,400 kilometers,
we were driving
Jatwara in Rajasthan
to Coorg to set up a
new hockey village.
And since three
months, we are working
with a local primary
school, grade one to seven.
We coach them in hockey and
we teach English and math
for grade one, two, and three.
They are all students from the
coffee plantation laborers.
And we hope that we can make
a difference there again.
I still believe that we made
a difference in Rajasthan.
We left our footsteps behind and
we took three of the children
with us, age 15, 16, and 17.
Shivani got selected as
the first and only girl
from Rajasthan for
the National Academy.
And she is playing at the
moment senior nationals
at the age of 15 for Rajasthan.
And I hope she has
a bright future.
And Rohit is from Goa.
He lived with me the last
three years in Rajasthan.
And I took him now to Coorg.
He has a learning disability.
He's suffering from
[INAUDIBLE],, so he
can't properly read and write.
But he's a brilliant
sportsperson,
a brilliant, excellent cook.
And he's preparing
each and everything.
He's making bamboo rafts.
And he's the king of
the jungle in Coorg.
And Deepak, he's 17.
He's also a very
good hockey player.
And he became our
plumber and electrician
because we live so
far away in the jungle
that, even if you call an
electrician or a plumber,
it takes 10 days
until somebody comes.
So he's keeping our activities
alive by making [NON-ENGLISH]
here and there.
So we brought these three
kids from Rajasthan.
So this is what we
could take with us.
And still kids are
calling us and asking us,
when do you come back or
did you open a new school?
We want to come to your school.
So at least for the children
I think we made a difference.
And we want to continue
the same thing in Coorg.
So that is Shivani.
She came as the first girl
to Germany two years back.
And she played an
excellent season
for one of the best
clubs in Germany.
And so now we are thinking if
we again bring her to Germany,
but we don't want to miss
out any trial for her
because you never know
when any selector is
spotting her and inviting her.
Because last year the trial
for the national academy,
she didn't manage
to get a space.
Because of all the struggles
that we had in Rajasthan,
she didn't practice
for some time.
But now in Coorg we trained
her well and she's fit.
And we hope that she
has a bright future
and will one day play for India.
So she was very easy going.
Coming from a village
the first day in Germany,
she was wearing the hot
pants of her German sister.
She was completely adapting
to the German lifestyle,
which is very surprising.
But I think that gives
her a really bright future
because she's very open minded.
Her English is pretty good.
She's doing now NOS,
means open schooling.
We teach her at home.
And she's doing that in
English, all subjects.
She's doing bio and
chemistry in English.
And this is Brijesh.
He was three times in Germany.
And he got a job with the
ThyssenKrupp Elevators
in Jaipur.
He only has a Hindi
medium 12th grade pass,
but he was so motivated.
And ThyssenKrupp said, OK,
he's so brilliant, we take him.
Unfortunately his
parents thought
more of a government
job and didn't
allow him to take the job.
Well, let's see, maybe he
will fight his way through.
But he is a very, very
bright and brilliant child
and he will make
his way I'm sure.
So there will be a day in
your life when you look back
and what you did in your
life and did it make sense?
Did it make any impact?
Did you make a difference?
And that was actually my
motivation to start this
project and to go ahead and
ahead and ahead because I think
I cannot forgive myself if
I stop because I think I can
still motivate and encourage
so many more children.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]